I remember one morning when I was in the
third grade my mom sent me to school
with a ghanaians staple dish called foo
foo foo foo is this white ball of starch
made of cassava and it's served with
light soup which is a dark orange color
and contains chicken and our beef it's a
savory flavorful dish that my mom
thought would keep me warm on a cold day
when I got to lunch and I opened my
thermos releasing these new smells into
the air my friends did not react
favorably what's that one of the masked
it's fufu I responded uh that smells
funny
what's the fufu they asked their
reaction made me lose my appetite I
begged my mother to never send me to
school with fufu again accident make me
sandwiches or a chicken noodle soup or
any of the other foods that my friends
were eating and this is one of the first
times I began to notice the distinction
between what was unique to my family and
was common for everyone else what was
Ghanaian and what was African and what
was American I'm a first generation
American both of my parents were
immigrants in fact my father Gabriel
came to the u.s. almost 50 years ago he
arrived in New York from a city called
Kumasi in a northern region of Ghana in
West Africa he came for school earning
his bachelor's degree in accounting and
eventually became an accountant my
mother Georgina joined him years later
she had a love of fashion and worked in
a sewing factory in lower Manhattan
until she saved up enough to open her
own women's clothing store I consider
myself an American and an African and a
good name and there's millions of people
around the world who are juggling these
different classifications they might be
Jamaican Canadians or Korean Americans
or Nigerian Brits and what makes our
stories and experiences different is
that we were born and raised in a
country different than our parents and
this can cause us to be misunderstood
when being viewed through a narrow lens
I grew up in New York which is home to
the largest number of immigrants
anywhere in the United States and you
would think growing up in a place like
New York it would be easy for a
first-generation person to find their
place but all throughout my childhood
there were these moments that formed my
understanding of the different worlds I
belong to when I was in the fifth grade
a student asked me if my family was
refugees I didn't know what that word
meant he explained to me that his
parents told him that refugees are
people from Africa who come to the u.s.
to escape death starvation and disease
so I asked my parents and they laughed a
bit not because it was funny but because
it was a generalization and they assured
me that they had enough to eat in Ghana
and came to the u.s. willingly these
questions became more complex as I got
older and junior high school was the
first time I went to school with a large
number of black American students and
many of them couldn't understand why I
sounded differently than they did it or
while my parents and seemed different
than theirs are you even black a student
next I mean I thought it was black I
thought my skin complexion settled that
asked my father about it and he shared
his own confusion over the significance
of that when he first came to the u.s.
he explained to me that when he was at
Ghana everyone was black so he never
thought about it but in the u.s. is a
thing but he he would say but you were
African remember that and he would
emphasize this even though many Africans
in the continent would only consider me
to be just an American these
misconceptions and complex cultural
issues and not just the inquiries of
children adults don't know who
immigrants are if we look at current
trends if I asked you what's the fastest
growing immigrant demographic in the
United States who would you think it was
9 out of 10 people tell me it's Latinos
but it's actually African immigrants how
about in academics what's the most
educated immigrant demographic a lot of
people presume it to be Asians but it's
actually Africa immigrants even in
matters of policy did you know that
three out of the eight countries in the
so-called travel ban are African
countries a lot of people assume those
targeted Muslims only live in the Middle
East but a lot of those bad people are
Africans so on these issues of education
and policy and religion a lot of things
we presume about immigrants are
incorrect even even if we look at
something like workplace diversity and
inclusion facts to you what gender
ethnicity combination is least likely to
be promoted to senior managerial
positions who would you think it was the
answer is not Africans this time and
it's not black women or men and it's not
Latin women or men it's Asian women or
at least likely to be promoted capturing
these stories and issues as part of my
work as a digital storyteller that uses
tech to make it easier for people to
find these stories this year I launched
an online gallery of portraits and
first-hand accounts for a project called
an OD the goal of an OD is to
highlight immigrants first-generation
immigrants just like me who carry this
kinship for the countries we grew up in
for the countries of origin and for this
concept called blackness I created this
space to be a cyber home for many of us
who are misunderstood in our different
home countries there are millions of
annuities who use hyphens to connect
their countries of origin with their
various homes in the US or Canada or
Britain or Germany in fact many people
you might know are nodi actors Issa Rae
Ann Digicel born OD colon Powell former
attorney General Eric Holder former
President of the United States Barack
Obama are all the children of African or
Caribbean immigrants but how much do you
know about us these this complicated
navigation is not just the experience of
first-generation folks we're so
intertwined in the lives and culture of
people in North America in Europe that
you might be surprised how critical we
are to your histories and future so
engages in conversation discover who
immigrants actually are and see us apart
from characterizations or limited media
narratives or even who we might appear
to be
we're walking melting pots of culture
and if something in that pot smells new
or different to you
don't turn up your nose access to share
thank you
[Applause]